alright so let's talk about what appears
to be the big story in the NFL prison
which is dak Prescott six total
touchdowns five incompletions Jason is
it fool's gold I'm generally one to pump
the brakes on anything that happens
between oh I don't know OTAs in May
between may and july through august i
generally am a bit of a skeptic and i'm
not going to crown this kid yet but i am
going to say what I tweeted the other
day which is this chain will be sort of
a national story coming out of this
entire preseason you know you think Tony
Romo plays I don't know maybe a half of
week three but of the preseason and then
they'll be plenty more for prescott in
week four i just wonder if a certain
point they put him under bubble wrap as
well because squarely he is the number
two there they believe and I believe
he's candy and maybe already is better
than a lot of sort of the veterans
you're going to find on the street and
when I rather have backed Prescott right
now going into a third preseason game
for Nick Foles going into his fourth
organization or whatever it is at least
third right I give me give me some a
Prescott there's a lot to see there
there's a lot of people excited and we
know that jerry jones and stephen jones
sometimes can get a little overexcited
and lose perspective but i was at the
game in la the first game he played and
just watching from that press box they
were ball you would see the ball come
out of his hand you would see the the
touchdown pass to Williams down the
sideline before that ball and its arc
and started sort of coming down on the
other end of the parabola you could
already tell like that's a perfect throw
four yards into the end zone like that's
not to touch down at this guy holds onto
the ball these were not sort of flu key
plays yeah they're just going to make
plays for you if you're willing
especially in the situation using the
put where you need to put it to let that
guy go up in battle and yeah a lot of
young quarterbacks won't do that they're
afraid to throw that interception there
this kids an athlete he's got some
Russell Wilson in them he's got a little
Aaron Rodgers in them maybe he turns out
to be just a guy
but there is a lot of clay to mold their
and if you can stay on the straight
narrow and avoid some of the pitfalls of
college life and some of his off-field
issues from that period of his life
there's a lot of upside there man that
kid he there's a little something there
you've had me at parabola there you go
like that's why I'm here you want to
pump the brakes but you throw on names
like Aaron Rodgers it is a thrilling
story if you're a cowboys fan because
they were furious that they didn't trade
up and grab Paxton Lynch who of course
went to the Broncos and who looked like
I thought Saturday night watching my
broncos like the best of the three
quarterbacks Trevor siemian get out
solid start clearly is not interested in
throwing the long ball but looks solid
in the short game and then he throws a
pick six incomes Mark Sanchez throw some
great balls and then does Mark Sanchez
things two fumbles and I think three or
four plays yes 51 career fumbles do they
rename sports authority field first or
do they name a starting quarterback
first and who is it I don't know that
they're going to be interested to
coronate someone now I mean I understand
what Cleveland did with rg3 but that was
a little different situation because
what at the point they made that move it
was going to be RT three and you want to
empower that kid if it was about you
know Josh McCown they want to going out
and that rg3 of Josh McCown was six or
seven years younger then they don't go
out and get rg3 so that that's a little
different this Bronco situation all
these guys need reps it is really truly
a viable competition and they're being
evaluated from throw to throw in each
practice and obviously in these games
and I've said all along that I'm not
worried about who throws the first pass
of the season for the Denver Broncos
that's a team that feels like it will
get better through the season at the
team that won a Super Bowl without a
quarterback last year and that's the
team that feels like the kids they took
in the first round has a lot of upside
and always took them for reason so
regardless of who throws the first pass
pass I think the last pass for this
isn't it's thrown by PacSun which I
think when you look at their overall pie
charts for a number of reps under center
when it's also
done for this season Lynch will be too
far and away the clubhouse leader
doesn't necessarily mean he has to start
week one but certainly he's being
groomed to be ready to play in that off
that sooner rather than later Elway will
be willing to take his lumps with that
kid early thinking that come November
you know late November early December
he's going to be far and away the best
quarterback on our roster if he's not
already now certainly through that
learning curve of the first couple
months of the season he will be and
let's try to have this kid this sort of
weapon in our arsenal this kids
athleticism all the things we think he
can he can do to help us get a play here
or play there because that's all we
really need it this defense doesn't fall
off precipitously we just can't have
butt fumble and you know we can't just
hope and think that maybe we found
something in Simeon we're going to have
to ride with this kid who what we valued
as a first rounder and again can he just
be better than or the same as Osweiler
last year this year knowing that next
year in the hereafter in the year after
we think he could be markedly better at
your point for all is deserved accolades
one of the great top five quarterbacks
of all time the Broncos won a Super Bowl
with arguably one of the five worst
quarterbacks in the league last year a
guy who i believe couldn't throw a
25-yard out I think Gary Kubiak did not
want him audible in anywhere near a pass
in that Super Bowl we're talking with
jason la canfora CBS Sports NFL reporter
and NFL is back in LA the Coliseum were
not quite at the brand new beautiful
stadium that they'll unveil and a couple
of years what's their quarterback
situation and I know the fan base was
really the story coming out of week two
of the preseason what is the picture of
NFL back in LA well I said I was at the
first game against the cowboys and they
had just under 90,000 there the
infrastructure needs some work if you're
going through an LA rams game I get
there early and by early i mean you know
a good three and a half hours before
kickoff if you can because it is a bit
of a nightmare getting it out of there I
I you know I'm a bit of I guess an old
school guy I like the Coliseum I think
it's cool there's so much history there
it's just the way that thinks
some of the sight lines from the press
box you know III think you could do
worse than have to play whatever 24
actually they're going to keep playing
games in london so whatever turns out to
be 21 you know regular season games
they're over three years and yeah
there's a lot of glitz and all that now
but that all that'll wear off and if
they don't win they won't be hot forever
they just got to hope they can go
sustain for a couple years until that
stadiums built after their quarterback
situation I I you know I think it's
always it should end up being tied to
these extensions I mean less need and
Jeff Fisher part probably going anywhere
and they've been talking about new deals
for a while if they get them then I can
see them saying let's just go with this
kid golf because he's going to make or
break how much of these extensions we
actually get to coach and general
manager ooh if that's still up in the
air and I think they have a pretty bad
San Francisco team week one I think they
try to win a couple games get everybody
in la all wrought up and then he'll
think maybe you know a fast start and we
get those extensions then so I think
that's probably in the back of
everyone's mind and Jared Goff just he's
not he's not ready yet and and will he
be ready two weeks from now no but
should he be able to close the gap on
someone like the cheese Keenum over the
course the first month of the season I
first six weeks of the season boy I
think you better not everyone is used to
the NFL back in LA one of the refs
penalized st. Louis in this game when
there was a neat I've been beat up
enough yeah alone and the fans did not
like that one bit um under the radar
story you mentioned rg3 who what's the
sneaky team to watch this year that
we're not looking i have not been there
yet myself i'm still going to try to get
there before camp closest but just
talking to other people who've been
around that gene just my sort of take on
that team last year and my overall
feelings about Jameis Winston I don't
hear a whole lot of buzz about Tampa
right it's kind of like the Jags and the
Raiders are hot and there's some who
think the Vikings are sort of on this
steady climb to being you know a
legitimate contender I don't hear much
about painful boy I think that's a
pretty good
in a mediocre division yes they've got a
bang heads with Carolina twice but I
like the offensive line at a time in
this league when no one's rating about
anyone's offensive line i love the young
quarterback i think he has sufficient
weapons there and i think just
schematically and from an idea
standpoint the defense will be addition
by subtraction by getting rid of that
old staff there is some some obviously
some talent there already Mikoyan and
the like and in there some guys who've
done some things in the league i think
they'll get that back in playing better
i think Tampa's kind of a scary keen
that i don't mean the i kn--again it
maybe I'm the wrong guy to ask because
as you travel this much you kind of feel
like you're in a vacuum sometimes but I
don't get the sense that there this sexy
sort of kick but I think they could be a
playoff game Jason is headed to Eagles
camp and Giants and Jets a must follow
on twitter also read them on
cbssports.com one quick thing before we
go and it's the Patriots Dion Lewis are
you hearing anything about that injury
how long they expect him to be out no I
haven't heard anything specific just yet
but obviously you know that's a
situation we're coming off how much time
he's missed and some of his injury
history in the path even before he got
to New England he was a guy who you know
would flash but have trouble staying on
the field obviously there's going to be
some concern there and he's someone who
in that offense it's been at that mean
do not did a guy he's been an absolute
difference maker some Sunday so any
prolonged absence by him coupled with
Brady situation and then obviously you
know we've seen Gronk hobbled here and
they're not the ideal way to start the
season but I've also in that division I
agree there I should I should miss
character I said it was an injury i
believe it was not a new injury it was
just cleaning out the the knee and
surgery did not necessarily take this
might just be a little bit of a cleaning
out my name is little time at JC his
knee history is long and deep
unfortunately yes I'm some injury issues
in Foxborough Jason locket for
appreciate you joining us grab a
cheesesteak in philly and talk to you in
with the giants and jets you got it
thanks buddy the Dan Patrick show
weekday
on audience